welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and have you ever wondered what Emperor
Palpatine's logo for the Galactic Empire
even means I mean like what is this it's
been around for so long and it's so damn
iconic but like why this specifically
not only will I explain the symbol of
the Galactic Empire today but I will
also explain the emblems for the first
order the final order and the universal
squads let's get into it speculation
Nation but like always be sure to head
on over to nerd riotop shop where you
can find our new Mandalorian inspired
gear we got a nice little this is the
way collection so head on over to
nerdrive.shop today so you can look like
the coolest nerd in your neighborhood so
what is the logo for Emperor Palpatine's
Galactic Empire supposed to be according
to issue 98 of Star Wars insiders
interview with John Malo the costume
designer for episodes four and five Malo
has said the black and white logo used
on Imperial helmets was designed by me
and was based on a series of sketches
working out the possible uses of shapes
occurring in 18th country fortifications
Malo is saying here that the design of
War forts of these 18th century inspired
his design for the Imperial crest for
the Galactic Empire and I can definitely
see that inspiration as 18th century War
forts were shaped a lot like stars which
is a quality that the imperial signia
has within its gear-like star shape but
also on top of this we cannot forget to
mention the obvious parallels that
George Lucas and the Gang were trying to
make between the Galactic Empire and
fascist Empires like Nazi Germany with
its use of black bold star imager
obviously Forts and fascism were huge
Inspirations here but all those facts
aside two questions still remain one why
did Malo design the logo after old ass
warforts anyway and two what exactly is
this weird star Fort symbol supposed to
be because that doesn't really answer
the question and luckily both those
questions can be wrapped up in one
answered the Galactic Empire Insignia is
none other than the biggest fort of all
the Death Star itself I know what you're
thinking Mt what are you talking about
the Death Star looks nothing like the
Imperial logo have you never seen a star
war the Imperial signia doesn't look
like the Death Star at first glance but
I'm fairly confident that it is here's
why what we are looking at when we see
the Galactic Empire Insignia is the very
heart of the Death Star itself the death
star's hyper matter Reactor Core aka the
thing that you want to shoot if you want
to blow up the Death Star in the
Millennium Falcon everything inside of
the circle in the Imperial signia is the
Death Star hyper matter Reactor Core a
reactor core that is generating the
power of a star within it which is why
there is a six-pointed radioactive star
in the middle of the hyper matter
reactor in the Imperial Insignia and a
circle dead center in the middle of that
star to represent the death star's outer
circular dish that fires the weapons and
now I know some of the other comments
are going to be like empty that doesn't
make sense because the death star dish
isn't directly in the center of the
Death Star so why would that Circle in
the middle of the star be that outer
dish of the Death Star well fun fact the
death star dish was originally supposed
to be dead center in the mid of the
Death Star before they changed the Death
Star design later on in post and this is
why you can still see the original
intended death star design when the
rebels look over the blueprints prior to
their assault on the Death Star in a new
hope that dishes right front and center
in these early designs with a center
dish in the Death Star very likely
informed John Malo as he created the
insignia for the Empire now if you look
at a blueprint for the Death Star you
can see that the Hyper Metal reactor of
the Death Star is shaped very similarly
to the Gear looking hyper marital
Reactor Core found within the Imperial
Insignia but time out now what is hyper
matter well in Star Wars when a star
explodes and causes the planets nearby
to crack open and have their planetary
cores expose the radiation turned the
matter within those cores into hyper
matter and Hyper matter is the type of
star fuel that Starships use to go into
light speed When someone tells Chewie to
punch it Piper matter is a super
powerful energy source made from
repurposed star matter that the emperor
was using to generate star our energy to
power his ultimate super weapon of death
which is why the insulation was called
Palpatine's Death Star because the power
of a star lies within the reactor core
and that is literally what the Insignia
is trying to tell us and why would
Emperor Palpatine choose the Death Star
as his symbol for the Galactic Empire
simple the Death Star is a scary ass
super weapon and fear is the way of the
Sith at its core Star Wars is a tale
about light and hope versus fear and
darkness that's literally all it is the
Sith especially Darth Sidious whose fear
as their greatest weapon as they believe
that wielding fear is the only way to be
truly strong and get what you want in
the Galaxy fear is the core of the dark
side of the force Palpatine being the
ultimate Sith Lord of fear in the Galaxy
will always use his ultimate symbols of
fear as his insignias and that's the
secret everybody all four of Palpatine's
emblems are his super weapons the
galactic Empire's logo is the Death Star
that's Palpatine's super weapon one and
look guys I like to live in the now as
in I need energy right now I don't have
time to run to the store to grab coffee
or something so I just pop one of these
a One-Shot energy
um well I feel the energy coming to my
body already Jesus Christ
once your Energy Chews are a healthy and
convenient energy boosting supplement
candy for gamers athletes YouTube hosts
and everyone really each energy shoe has
75 milligrams of pure caffeine plus 600
milligrams of additional New Tropics to
give you a serious energy boost that
works immediately as you chew and man
does it work like as I was chewing that
I felt the alertness and power coursing
through my veins like put it directly
into my veins I say the focus shoes are
great when you need to concentrate and
they give you a natural boost of energy
with Beast C D and E vitamins plus zinc
to help with immune system support and
the amino acid tyrosine but my favorite
ingredient is the blue raspberry flavor
rasposine both Energy Chews and focus
shoes are plant-based naturally
sweetened and designed to give you the
energy and focus that you need without a
bunch of fillers and chemicals and
so get started with one shot energy
today by going to one shotenergy.com new
rockstars for 10 off of your order that
is oneshotenergy.com new rockstars for
10 off your order we think one shot
energy for sponsoring this video and
giving all the viewers the extra shot of
energy that they need to survive and
thrive and be nerdy all the time and
what's Palpatine's super Weapon 2 a
little something called operation Cinder
and it's a protocol that Palpatine
placed should he ever die to have
satellite dishes of lasers destroy a
bunch of planets in his Empire as
punishment for the Empire failing to
prevent his death the most pettiest move
of all time it was super messed up like
Naboo almost got destroyed from there a
clinic called vardos got destroyed by it
and remember when Bill Burr's character
migs mayfeld shot that Imperial officer
in Mando season two it's because he was
traumatized from operation Cinder when
that super weapon destroyed the entire
planet of burning Khan now if you played
Star Wars Battlefront 2 you'll know that
it was the job of Iden versio's Inferno
Squad to make sure that Palpatine's
operation Cinder went exactly as planned
which is why their logo is literally
three laser beams of operation Cinder
hitting a circular Planet they were
meant to bring The Inferno of operation
Cinder and their logo reflects that it's
literally operation Cinder and
Palpatine's super weapon 3 was of course
the first orders Starkiller base in the
first order's logo is exactly that a
star being darkened and killed we
witnessed Starkiller base absorbing the
power of stars and channeling that power
directly into the core of the planet
alum in order to fire their Planet
obliterating lasers this is why I
believe the first order logo is a
darkened sun inside of a hexagon with
the hexagon shape in Star Wars largely
being associated with the rigid Imperial
ideas and systems of order so this black
star inside of the hexagon of the first
order logo symbolizes the first order
harnessing the power of dead stars for
their Starkiller weapon and much like
the hyper matter found in the Death Star
Starkiller base is the result of
Palpatine using a coarse combination of
Starlight energy and planetary core
energy to fuel a super weapon of fear
and finally the emperor's super Weapon 4
his last great super weapon in the
series was of course the Sith final
order Fleet that emerged from the
surface of hexagonal itself in its why
the final order has a diamond shaped
logo placed in front of a circle I
believe the final order logo is an image
of a diamond-shaped Sith Star Destroyer
hovering over a circular Planet as that
was the exact purpose of the final order
Fleet with Death Star super lasers
strapped onto them to hover over planets
wipe them out and spread more fear
across the Galaxy and all the final
order fleets wear that logo on their
hats for that reason but yeah that's
what Palpatine's four logos represent
thank you guys so much for watching this
video you can follow me at Mass
retainment you want to see you tweet
some really weird stuff and really fun
theories but more importantly you can
find new rockers wherever we are on the
social medias but yes thank you guys so
much for watching I love you guys so
much and I'll see you guys later goodbye
[Music]
foreign